>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Good
morning and welcome to our seventh
of eight talks in our NASA
lecture series this year.
I am Stephanie Marcus from
the science technology
and business division.
And, today I think we can say,
Houston we don't have a problem,
because Houston is world
champions in baseball, hooray!
[ laughs ]
And I did see someone from NASA
from the Johnson Space Center who is
in an orange space suit and had
all kinds of things hung on him.
Go Astros!
So, exoplanet.
Everyone seems to love them, it's
not enough to love our own planet,
we have to love that which
we know very little about.
And today we have the perfect
person to tell us about exoplanets.
Our speaker is Dr. Padi Boyd,
and she's chief of the exoplanets
and stellar astrophysics
laboratory at NASA Goddard.
She has her B.S. in
astronomy from Villanova.
And she was originally more of
a music, artsy kind of person
and then she turned
towards astronomy later
in high school and look her now!
And then she went to Drexel
and got a M.S. and PhD
in physics and atmospheric science.
She's been involved with exoplanets
way back because she has worked
with the Kepler Mission and
the Hubble Space telescope.
And now she is also the director
of the Guest Investigator Program
for the Transiting Exoplanet
Survey Satellite mission,
which we like to call TESS.
And we did have a speaker in 2015,
almost two years ago in October,
Steven Reinhert, who
talked about TESS.
And at that time, it was
supposed to launch in 2017
but Dr. Boyd says March 2018
is the expected launch date.
We do have a webcast of the TESS
program if you don't learn enough
about exoplanets today,
but I'm sure you will.
So, please join me in
welcoming Dr. Padi Boyd.
[ Applause ]
>> Padi Boyd: Well, thank
you very much Stephanie.
Can you all her me okay?
It was a real pleasure to be
here at the Library of Congress.
I am really excited to visit the
building and the people and to talk
to you about the very exciting
field of extra solar planets,
or exoplanets, as we call them.
Planets around other stars.
So I thought I was start off with
a very thought invoking engraving
that most people have seen in some
time or another in their lives.
It's from the late 1880s.
And it was an engraving that
first appeared in a textbook
about meteorology, the
study of the atmosphere.
But it's so thought provoking and
it really has so many things going
on in it that many people can
read a lot into this engraving.
It's someone who's peering
beyond what is known around them
and the world around them.
The sun, the moon, the stars.
And they are peeking through
and they are catching a glimpse
of what's going on beyond.
In this particular image you can see
the familiar, trees on the earth,
the sun setting, moon
and stars in the sky.
And then beyond that, a picture
of a mechanistic solar system.
So some people associate
this image with the birth
of the scientific revolution
because human beings,
ever since we've been able to
sit around a campfire and talk
to each other and share ideas, we've
known that some stars are the same
in relation to each
other every night
and that others were wanderers.
The wanderers were the planets,
been known about for centuries,
but it was only during
the scientific revolution
where scientists like Kepler and
Galileo put the picture together,
and Isaac Newton, of what was
really going on in our solar system.
So that's a moment that shows
you a kind of transformation,
someone seeing the world in
a new way for the first time.
And this has happened
so many times in science
and I think it's happening
right now in astrophysics
as we're exploring the
planets close to earth now.
Oops, don't know what that musical
signal was, but we're still seeing.
I think this was a very
transformational moment
for many of us too.
Many of us who are old enough
to remember that picture
which is called Earth Rise.
I'm just barely old enough to
remember when it first appeared
and it made an impact to
everyone on planet earth.
It was really the first time
that the human race could think
about what the planet earth
looks like from a distance.
These were the Apollo astronauts and
as they were orbiting the moon one
of them turned around and took
that beautiful shot of the earth.
The sun is eliminating both
the moon and the earth.
And you get that sense of a pale,
small, blue dot that is floating
in a dark, dark universe.
It really gave us a sense of our
perspective of the solar system.
But, up until -- even at that time,
the solar system was the only set
of planets that we knew
for a fact existed.
We'd known about them
for thousands of years.
We'd put them together in a picture
of how the solar system works
over the last several hundred years.
So we know that the planets in
our solar system orbit the sun,
which is a typical star compared
to the other stars in the sky.
And the planets are on orbits
that are defined by their distance
from the star, the closer
they are, the faster they go.
And we knew a lot about
our solar system.
We could study it, we sent probes
to it in the 60s and 70s and beyond.
We learned a lot about the
planets that orbited our star,
but for so long it was
the only solar system
that we really knew anything about.
And I've picked this picture
from an Issue Asimov book,
because Isaac Asimov was
so amazingly talented
at marrying the science and
his science fiction ideas.
So he really brought
science to humanity
through his science fiction stories
and he also embedded
them with great science.
Of course, science fiction knew
of many planets beyond
our solar system.
There are so many examples of
stories that are so important to all
of us that really depend
on this idea that planets
like earth are plentiful
throughout the galaxy and even
in galaxies far, far away.
So there are many scientists
who are interested in exoplanets
who can tie their first
moment of really thinking
about planets beyond our solar
system to some moments in Star Trek
or Star Wars or something where they
were exploring planets beyond our
solar system.
But for so long, those were
just dreams and stories.
When we'd look up at the night
sky, this is a picture actually
from Joshua Tree, of
a beautiful dark sky.
And you can see the band
of the Milky Way there.
The sun is one of hundreds
of billions
of stars in the Milky Way galaxy.
And some lucky nights
we're lucky to really look
at a huge swath of stars.
And for generations all we
could do is look at those stars
and wonder, is the sun unique?
Are we the only star out there
out of hundreds of billions
that have planets around them?
And that was the only
they we knew for sure.
But scientists are persistent.
Our technology develops
and allows us to learn more
and more as time goes on.
So one of the reasons we
didn't know about stars
that had other planets was because
they're very, very hard to detect.
The stars light vastly
outshines a planets light.
Planets are just little specks
compared to giant stars.
Ten billion times brighter
typically.
But our technology got
better and better so instead
of seeing our planets we could allow
ourselves to detect them indirectly.
One method is called the
radial velocity method.
And what this relies on are
just simple Newtonian mechanics,
you remember Isaac Newton
put together a picture
of how the solar system works
and it's based on gravity.
And we know that all stars
are obeying these laws.
So if a star has a planet
orbiting it, we know from Newton
that they're orbiting a
common center of mass.
It's not the star being
completely static
and the planets orbiting
around the star.
They're actually both in orbit.
The planets orbit is bigger
because the center of mass,
where most of the mass is,
is inside the star typically
for a small planet.
But that doesn't mean the
start doesn't move at all.
If our technology gets good enough
we can detect that tiny wobble
from a star that's telling us
that a planet is imparting
that wobble on it.
It's called the Radial
Velocity Method.
And the was really getting
going in the mid 90s.
Of course we were looking for solar
systems that looked a lot like ours.
We knew big planets were going
to be the ones that imparted
that signal strongest on the stars.
But the big planets in our solar
system are Jupiter, Saturn,
they are way, way far
beyond where the earth is.
They take years to go around the
sun, 5, 10 maybe even longer years.
So people were looking for signals
in their data from big planets
that they thought would be
like Jupiter and Saturn.
They were so focused on what
they were expecting to see
from our solar system that
many of the scientists
who were working this area
missed the first signals.
This is actually the
discovery image.
It's actually the confirmation
image by a group, Jeff Marcy
and Paul Butler, who confirmed
a planet call 51 Peg b,
orbiting the star 51 in
the constellation Pegasus.
So what you see there is going
up and down is the velocity
of the star coming towards
us and moving away from us.
Towards and away, in a perfectly
periodic way that's telling us what
the orbit of that planet was.
It was actually on a few
days orbit, less than 5 days.
Much, much closer than any planet in
our solar system and quite massive,
almost the mass of Jupiter, to
be able to impart that signal.
This was a watershed event.
It was like the earth
rise image for scientists
because we now had evidence
that there were planets
around other stars and that first
planet was so surprising compared
to what our solar system
has that we had
to rethink how we were
looking for exoplanets.
So it's hard to read
this in the light,
but this is artists impression
of what 51 Peg b looks like.
Its orbital period is
about four or so days.
It has a very hot temperature
because it's so,
so close to the sun,
1800 degrees Fahrenheit.
That's really hot you
don't want to live there.
We don't think it's
a habitable planet.
And then as we start
thinking about what that means
to be habitable we start to get
a sense that planets like earth,
maybe Venus, maybe Mars, are
in a region near our star
called the Goldilocks zone,
where they're not too hot for
water to exist on the surface
and they're not too cold for
all the water to be frozen.
So we started to find planets but
they were not in the habitable.
And exoplanet discovery
started to take off.
There are several different methods
you can use to discover exoplanets.
And so in 2009 NASA finally
completed a mission called Kepler.
Kepler was actually dreamed
of decades before it was built
and launched by principal
investigator Bill Borucki.
He knew theoretically,
he wrote a paper,
that said if you were very
careful with your photometry,
how you measure your light, that you
could detect a tiny dip in the light
as a planet passed in front of
a star, that's called a transit.
So finally, Kepler was launched
in 2009 by NASA with one goal
and one goal alone, to answer the
question, how common is a planet
like the earth -- so a small
rocky planet like we live on,
how common are those planets
around stars like the sun
at a distance that's
in the Goldilocks zone?
In other words, how common are we?
Here's a transit, many of you may
have actually seen this transit.
It's the transit of Venus.
Did you see it?
Anyone? It was visible
in the morning sky,
I think that was the one
that was in the morning.
You could get up on your
roof with the right equipment
and watch the transit of Venus.
They happen very, very
rarely but they happen
in pairs a few years apart.
Venus is about the size of the earth
and that's going right
across our sun.
So you could see all kinds
of things in that movie.
Let's see if I can start it over.
So you see that the sun actually
looks darker on the edges
and gets brighter as we go in.
You can start to see
some granulation
on the surface of the sun.
Stars are actually pretty
active, they're not super quiet.
Our star is actually
very quiet as stars go.
And you can start to see that
haze around Venus, the atmosphere.
Venus has a very thick atmosphere.
Some of the suns rays are getting --
they're not passing
through the atmosphere,
it's actually dimmer around there.
And then as it comes off you can
get a sense of the size of Venus.
It's covering just a
little piece of the sun,
so it's light is going
to dim just a bit.
Here's an example of
what Jupiter would look
like if it passed in
front of the sun.
It would cover up about a
hundredth the size of the sun.
And you'd see a dip that you could
measure and you could get a sense
of that size if you knew
the star size very well.
Here's what the earth
would look like.
That's hard.
Maybe you can't even see it but
it's there on the right side.
If they were a bit more high
definition or darker you'd be able
to see some features on the sun,
sun spots, that are the same size
or even bigger than the planet.
So it's a real challenge to
try to disentangle the signal
from the stars from the
signal of the transit.
But Kepler was meant to do this.
How did it do it?
Well we launched Kepler
into a really interesting
orbit called an Earth Trailing
Heliocentric Orbit.
So it's almost on the
same orbit as the earth
but it was a little bit further
out, so it lags behind us.
And that orbit was a very good orbit
for us to stare without blinking
at this patch right above
the Milky Way galaxy.
It's near the Cygnus and
Lyra region of our Milky Way.
If you're familiar with the
constellations you'll know to look
out in the summer time near the
summer triangle and if you were
to stare there without
blinking for four
and a half years you would be
doing what Kepler was doing.
[laughs] Why is it so important
that it's stared without blinking?
Well a transit like I showed
you of Venus, I said only occurs
from where we can see
every 200 years or so
and it only lasts a
very short while.
Well the same thing is true, a
planet like the earth is only going
to transit it's star once a
year, once every 365 days.
We have to be perfectly aligned
in order that that planet passes
in front of the star
as we're viewing it
from our vantage point
in the Milky Way.
It turns out that we
expect only about one
in a hundred stars are
going to be aligned with us
so that we would see transits.
So you have to look
at a lot of them.
So we looked at 150,000 stars,
getting a brightness reading
every 30 minutes for four
and a half years pausing only to
turn around and dump the data back
to earth so that we could
detect these tiny transits in 1%
of those stars, if
planets were plentiful.
Of course one of the
questions Kepler wanted
to answer was how plentiful
are they?
What I told you is that one in
a hundred stars would be aligned
so that we could see the planets.
But if only one in a hundred stars
has a planetary system well then
your statistics go way down.
You have to look at a lot
to get some meaningful
number if planets are rare.
So we didn't know before Kepler
launched what the situation was.
So here's a graph that
gives you our picture
of exoplanets before Kepler
launched, on the eve of our launch.
And there up at the
top are several methods
that we can use to detect planets.
There's the radial velocity
method and the transit method
that we've just talked about.
You can also imagine if you're close
enough you could see the planet
if you had the right technology and
there's a couple blue ones on there.
Eclipse timing is something where
if you have some very precise way
of timing a system like
neutron stars that are
like rock solid clocks, you
could see difference in the times
that you expect versus the times
that you measure and you can infer
that a planet is there from that.
No Kepler points on this yet
because Kepler didn't launch yet.
So what we see there are a
bunch of massive planets.
Planets bigger than Neptune
and Jupiter, up near the top.
And we see a whole bunch of
planets that are very short orbits.
So at the bottom we're look at
how long is the orbit in days,
and you see that pink chunk of
pink ones from the transit method.
They're all like on a
week or shorter orbit.
So we see a lot of massive
planets, we see a lot of planets
that are very close to their stars.
None of those are planets
like the earth orbiting
in the Goldilocks zone.
So let me show you what the first
few years of Kepler taught us.
>> Whoa!
>> Padi Boyd: There's
another transformative moment
in our understanding of what
planets are like in our galaxy.
So remember that's just a
little patch of our galaxy,
it's actually 10 degree
by 10 degrees,
so it's a fairly large
patch of the sky compared
to something that Hubble can see.
But you can see what's
happening is that we're going
down to much smaller sizes and in
fact, if you look at where most
of those yellow dots are collecting
they're collecting near the
small planets.
We're not picking up those big
Jupiter's, they're the easy ones
to find, that's why we found them
when we first started looking
because you can't miss them.
They're in plain sight.
And you can also see
that we're pushing
out a little bit towards
longer periods and there's
of course still some Jupiter's up
there and still some hot Jupiter's.
Let me show you the newest
catalog of Kepler planets.
You may have seen a press
release related to this
within the last few months.
The Kepler team, the
Kepler mission is done now.
It's on a new mission called K2
and what the team is doing is
they're compiling all their
statistics and really improving
their pipeline software
that finds the planets to give
us a sense of what Kepler found.
So the little yellow ones are the
newest planets and you can see
that the improved processing
it really, really pushing us
down towards those smaller
planets and towards longer orbits.
You see where the earth is there,
we're really starting to fill
in that region of planets
that are on earth like orbits.
We're still only talking
about a couple dozen planets.
But remember, Kepler
looked for four or so years,
you've got to see several transits
before you know you have a planet.
So really, finding
something at around an earth
or a Mars orbital period is at
the limits of what Kepler can do.
We found that planets
were everywhere.
This is an image that shows
you that region of the sky
but now plotting some of those
planets down on it as a function
of how big the planets were.
So there's big planets and small
planets, they're everywhere
in the region that we looked.
There's no preferential treatment.
There's no stars that have
them and don't have them.
But one of the really key points
that we found when we found
so many transiting
planetary star systems was
that planets are everywhere.
You can take what Kepler found and
you can extract that to determine
that pretty much every star out
there should have a planetary system
and that one in five probably has a
planet about the size of the earth
in an orbit where you
could have liquid water,
a habitable zone planet,
one in five.
So when you look up at the
sky next time, count ten star,
two of them probably have an
earth like planet in orbit.
Earth like is a tricky thing to say.
I'll say earth size instead.
Here's the distribution of
planets, of the planetary candidates
as of a couple of years ago.
So here's some surprises.
So you see Jupiter sized planets
and larger are actually fairly
rare in the Kepler haul.
We've got a couple
in our solar system
but most solar system
that we interrogated
with Kepler really didn't
have a huge planet like that.
Also, we see a bunch of earth size
planets and a huge number of things
that are bigger than
earth, but not too much.
One and a half to two times
the size of the earth,
we call those Super Earths.
And then you see this big, big
peak at around Neptune or so,
they're actually a little
bit smaller than Neptune
up to Neptune size and we
call those Sub-Neptune's.
And as the data got better, this is
actually from that recent catalog
that I was talking about before.
You could get much better
statistical insight into the sizes
of the planets, we actually see
something we call the Fulton Gap.
What it tells us is in
those small planets that are
so numerous they appear to come
in two separate categories,
two separate populations.
One that we think are
probably very similar
to the earth like Kepler-452b.
And by similar, I mean
a small rocky planet
with just a little
big of an atmosphere.
Because believe it or not the earth
has kind of a tenuous atmosphere.
And then we think the other
population are planets
that are probably right around
the same size in their core
but for some reason
they have attracted
and retained a huge atmosphere,
bigger than Venus,
maybe close to Neptune.
The atmosphere being so big that
you can't really have life there,
it would be way too dense.
Two populations of small
planets and a gap in the middle
that may be telling us about two
different formation mechanisms
for the same kind of planets
or the similar sized planets.
But what's really surprising about
this type of result to me is that --
remember we were learning
so much about planets before
by studying our solar system.
Now what we're finding
out from Kepler is
that the two most common type of
planets out there, Super Earths
and Mini Neptune's, we don't
have one in our solar system.
That's interesting.
Were they here?
Did they go somewhere?
Did our solar system
form in a different way?
Or is it just small
number statistics?
Wee know a lot about one.
This is a really thought provoking
animation that I love to show,
it's called the Kepler
Digital Orrery.
When scientists first figured
out the solar system they love
to build things call orreries,
where you could turn a crank,
you can see it on [inaudible]
cover there
and the planets would
start to go around.
They're like little
mechanical systems.
This is basically that idea applied
to the Kepler multiplanetary
systems,
because something else we didn't
know for sure until Kepler launched,
is whether solar systems,
systems of planets with more
than one planet were common or rare.
Now what we're finding from Kepler
is that they are incredibly common,
it's very common to
find systems of planets.
And when you find systems of
planets around a single star,
it's much more powerful
because each one
of those planets can tell you
something about the same star.
And since the planets interact
with each other gravitationally they
can even tell you about the masses
of the planets themselves.
So you may have seen as it
zoomed out and zoomed back in,
that you started to see our
solar system on the same scale.
So again, just another
graphical reminder
that Kepler was really studying
those tight, tight solar systems
where the planets are going around
weeks, months, out to a year or so.
Whereas our solar system, we know
of things on very, very long orbits.
So, you may have also noticed
that there is a difference
in the star type, the star type
then planet temperature up there.
Well that's because Kepler was
looking in one region of space
at about 150,000 pre-selected stars.
We selected most of them to be very
similar to the sun but it turns
out that there are just a whole
bunch of starts that are much,
much smaller than the sun.
There's a distribution
of stellar sized.
And the sun, while it's a
normal star in some ways,
the most typical star in the milky
way is actually a low mass star,
what we call a M star.
It's just a way of
categorizing stars.
Some of them are only
10% the mass of the sun.
What that means is that if an earth
sized planet is transiting a much
smaller, much dimmer star, then
the transit signal is a lot deeper.
So you see on the right, a
transit signal around Kepler 186,
which was one of the
first earth sized planet
in a habitable zone
announced by Kepler.
Compared to what the earth
transiting the sun looks like.
Much, much easier to find
those earth sized planets
around the smaller stars.
Here's a gallery of some of the
small, hopefully earth like,
but certainly close to earth sized
planets the Kepler has found.
Showing you their size
by how big the circle is.
There's earth up there, sort of
towards the top and the middle.
And giving you a sense
of the habitable zone.
We're sort of right
smack in the middle
of the habitable zone we thinking.
Wee could live, we
could exist closer in.
We'd have a completely
different climate,
we'd probably be a
different species.
We could also be pushed out, we
would have different characteristics
as well but we believe liquid
water could have formed and existed
on the surface and life
could have flourished.
And we can set that Goldilocks
zone, or habitable zone
by how much radiation planets
are receiving from their stars.
So on the top axis there
you're getting a sense
of what type of star.
Are these planets round?
And how much sunlight they're
getting from their star.
How is that habitable zone defined.
So you see we've got a
lot of smaller planets
around the smaller stars for the
reason we talked about before
and even in the earths region there
are a number of planets there.
So they are still very hard to
detect but we are finding them,
dozens of habitable zone
planets found by Kepler.
This is again an update
from that latest catalog.
The yellow ones are the new ones.
So you can see that last run
of the Kepler data found habitable
zone planets and small planets
that were getting closer
to earth analogs
which is exactly what we were
expecting would happen with Kepler.
That as the data came
down and we got more data
and we refined our methods that
we would be able to really push
down into habitable zone
around a star like the sun.
So I mentioned that the M stars
are abundant in our galaxy.
Seven out of ten stars in the
milky way are thought to be M stars
and the stars closest
to us are small stars.
So they're important.
They're becoming increasingly
important as we think
about finding planets,
because what Kepler told us is
that planets are everywhere and
we saw that a lot of M stars seem
to have a lot of smaller
planets around them.
That it's common to make smaller
planets around smaller stars.
And the other thing that's
really exciting about them is
that the habitable zone is really
crunched in around these small stars
and that means that that
transit that you're looking for,
or anything that you're
looking for on
that periodic signal,
happens much more often.
Weeks typically.
So if you want to observe something
over and over again for a planet,
a small planet around
an M star is going
to give you a lot more opportunities
in a given say, observing season
at a telescope, than something
like earth around the sun.
So a lot of our attention is being
turned towards the smaller M stars
in the galaxy now when we
think about how we're going
to take the next steps from Kepler
and find those really
earth like planets.
But there are some problems and
some challenges with M stars.
It turns out that M stars
are incredibly active.
So sometimes you're probably
hearing about solar flares
that they're predicting are going
to perhaps impact your cable signal
or maybe the GPS for a little while.
Or maybe you're going to be
able to see an aurora down here
in southern latitudes
because of the suns activity.
Remember I told you the sun is
a very calm, low activity star.
M stars are hundreds
of times more active.
They give out huge flares
that dwarf solar flares
and they do it much more typical.
So much more often.
This means that any planet that's
really close to that M star
and going around really
quickly, could be bombarded,
probably is bombarded with high
energy radiation all the time.
So even if they're in that habitable
zone it could be a trick for it
to really be something where you
could get habitability happening.
Also, planets that are
close to stars tend
to synchronize their
orbit and their spin,
just like the moon has
synchronized its orbit and spin
with respect to the earth.
So we always see the same face
of the moon facing the earth.
A planet would always see
the same part of the sun.
I should say it the
other way around.
If you're on a planet that's in one
of these M star orbits you're quick
likely to have got tidally locked
and you could either be
on that side of the planet
that always faces the
sun or maybe on the side
that never faces the sun.
Or maybe lucky enough to
be on that Terminator area.
Maybe the planet would
wobble a little bit
and you would get something
like a day/night cycle.
But typically we expect
these to be tidally locked
which gives you all kinds
of habitability issues.
But we're still working hard to
study these phenomena and figure
out what could really be
going on in these systems
that are so different from ours.
And the thing that I think is really
exciting about this particular area
of research is it really
joins together all the areas
of astrophysics.
So you have to understand our
sun very well, the flare dynamics
and time variability, to have
some sense of other stars that are
like it and to be able to compare
what's happening on other stars
as far as their flares go with
what we know so well about the sun.
The sun is very well studied.
We have reams of data about the sun.
Also, we're learning about
what happens to these planets
around other stars by studying
the planets in our own system.
Getting better refinements of
how our own solar system formed.
Why is there water in some
places and not others?
Was there water that
escaped, for example in Mars?
And we have a lot of
information about the atmospheres
on the other planets in our solar
systems because we've sent probes
and we keep sending probes
and the probes get better
and better all the time.
So we're able to take the
earths scientists ability
to model the earths atmosphere
and apply it to planetary
atmospheric modeling and then tying
that with the suns variability,
getting a picture or a model
of what the exoplanet
atmospheres could really be like.
So it's just a very exciting time
to be in any area of astrophysics
because anything that
you do has some tie
in to understanding the
atmosphere's around these planets.
So we know the planets are there and
our next step is how are we going
to find out about the
atmospheres of these planets?
What's in the atmosphere?
How big is the atmosphere?
Do they even have an atmosphere?
I'm going to take a little bit
of a detour now to a system
that got a lot of attention
earlier this year.
And this is called
the Trapeus system.
Has anybody heard of the
Trappist system before?
Yeah! It was very exciting, it was
one of NASA's biggest days as far
as like communicating
a message goes.
A lot of people heard
about the Trappist result,
downloaded the images and
watched the press conference
and read articles online.
What's Trappist?
Trappist is a really small star,
like we were talking about,
that was discovered with a ground
based telescope to transit.
And the team that discovered
it convinced the Spitzer Space
Telescope to stare at it
for a very, very long time.
This is 500 hours of Spitzer
data, again uninterrupted.
Because they knew that there
were a couple of systems
that were transiting
and if they looked
for a long time maybe
they'd find more.
So this is the discovery
image of many
of the planets in the
Trappist system.
There are actually seven
earth sized planets --
earth size-is planets
in this system.
They're small planets around
a small star and they're
about 40 light years away.
It's actually really
close in the milky way.
It would take us about 800,000
years to get there if we were going
at the new horizon speed,
the fastest thing we've
ever sent away from earth.
But it's still close.
Relatively speaking it's close.
Some people actually think of the
Trappist system as more analogous
to Jupiter and it's moons.
Jupiter has moons that are
about the size of the earth too.
And Trappist is a really small star.
You could fit the Trappist system
well within our solar systems.
Those planets orbit Trappist on
orbits of days, weeks and months.
So they're transiting all the time.
Sometimes you can see two of
them transiting at the same time
and if they're really a lot
alike you can boost the signal
of what you're detecting by looking
at the two planets passing in front
of the sun instead of one.
So there's a lot of
interest in Trappist.
That we know that they're
small, we saw them interacting
with each other gravitationally
so we can measure their masses.
They are so close that it's a fairly
bright target even though it's a dim
star absolutely, it's
still close enough
that we can observe it very well.
It's going to be observed
for decades,
it's going to be a touchstone
system in our exoplanet studies.
This is just another example of the
Trappist planets on top compared
to some of the smaller bodies
in our solar system,
the terrestrial bodies.
And you can see where it says
planet radius there, the third down,
that they're all pretty darn
close to one earth radius.
So they're a really good size.
And some of them are
in the habitable zone.
They should have formed in a place
around that star where they had ice
and water and as they
migrated in kept some
of that water on their surface.
So they're also excellent
candidates for looking
for life signs or at
least water signs.
How are we going to do
this and how are we going
to find more systems like Trappist?
Well, we're going to launch
something called TESS;
Transiting Exoplanet
Survey Satellite
as Stephanie mentioned earlier.
It's actually a fairly small
telescope, it's four cameras
that are pointed in a row.
And it's going to launch in 2018
March and it has one purpose.
It's going to do an all sky survey
of the stars near us to look
for planets transiting
nearby bright stars.
So Kepler wanted a
statistical answer and it looked
at stars that were very far away.
TESS is going to look for
those transiting planets now
around our nearest neighbors.
We know they're out there,
we're going to find them.
Here's an overview of the mission.
It's what we call a
NASA Explorer mission.
NASA has big missions like Hubble
and medium missions like Explorers
where you launch balloons
and sounding rockets as well.
It's managed at Goddard.
The lead institution and science
team is led by George Ricker at MIT.
Being built down in
Virginia at Orbital Now.
The beautiful picture of
it all coming together.
It's going to take two
years to survey the sky.
It's going to do the southern
hemisphere first for one year
and then it's going to turn over
and do the northern hemisphere.
And they've designed it so that they
can detect enough exoplanets this
way that they can then go to the
ground based follow up observatories
to confirm them and
measure their masses;
fifty small planets
at the end of this.
These cameras are really wide
field compared even to Kepler.
So one camera, you could
actually put the entire Orion
constellation into.
Go out some night when it's
clear and look at Orion,
it is a huge constellation.
That's one of four cameras.
So it's really looking
at a huge swath
of the nearby stellar neighborhood.
Here's a comparison of
the Kepler search space.
So Kepler was looking at
one region, basically a cone
where the average distance of
the stars was 3,000 light years.
And it only looked at
less than 1% of the sky.
That is TESS's search space.
Going to look at virtually
the entire sky.
There are definitely some
gaps, but those stars are more
like 200 light years near us.
Lots, lots, closer.
They're going to be brighter
and they're going to
be all over the sky.
There it is.
It's taken a long time to take
a picture like this of TESS.
But that's the solar array test that
the space craft is all put together.
That's the antenna you're
seeing looking at you,
that's going to beam our data
down every 13.7 days once
we go around that orbit.
You can't really see the
cameras but they're on top.
So we're really excited for TESS.
We know it's going to
find transiting planets.
We can't wait to get to
the telescopes and find
out what their masses are and
maybe have another few Trappist
like systems where we can
really start to figure
out what's going on
in the atmospheres.
But all of these missions I've
been talking about so far,
really what they're doing
is discovering exoplanets.
They're collecting where
the exoplanets are.
And we're learning about
the sizes of the exoplanets,
that there's a wide variety of sizes
but we don't know very much more.
There's more than 4,000
exoplanets known right now,
more than 4,000 just from
Kepler alone as candidates.
We're not sure what any of
them really look like the way
that our own solar
system planets are known.
So how are we going to get there?
Well we have to turn to the most
powerful telescopes that exist today
and that we're launching soon and
that we're planning for the future
in order to really get these
answers, we've got enough data now
that we can really design
these experiments well
to take these next steps.
So I'm going to take a few minutes
to just talk at what direction --
one of the directions
that we're going in.
This is an artist's concept
of some work that's being done
with the Hubble Space
Telescope right now.
It's been going on
for the last few years
and there are several large programs
that are devoting Hubble
space telescope time
to measuring the spectra of what
we call those "Hot Jupiter's",
those very massive planets.
To look for spectral signatures,
little parts of the light
that are missing, where elements
have been absorbed by the light.
So what we see here is a signature
of methane in a planet's atmosphere.
Methane is one of the gases that
we think could be a biosignature.
A lot of biological
material makes methane.
It's not easy to keep methane in
an atmosphere if there's no source
for it in certain conditions.
So methane is exciting.
We can actually see it
in a Hubble spectrum.
These are just really the baby
steps that we're taking here.
That doesn't tell you where
the methane came from.
It doesn't tell you a lot
about the atmosphere other
than that you've seen a
methane line in absorption.
But we do know that the James
Webb Space Telescope is going
to be able to take the next step.
So James Webb Space Telescope
is launching in 2019.
You can see it's quite a bit bigger
than the Hubble Space Telescope.
Hubble Space Telescope mirrors
2.4 mirrors, JWST dwarfs it.
It has hexagonal mirrors
that come together
and can reposition themselves.
It has a sun shield there at
the bottom that's the size
of a tennis court that's going to
keep it very cold because it's going
to make measurements
in the infrared,
so beyond the red part
of the visible spectrum.
That's where a lot of exciting
stuff happens in astrophysics both
for exoplanets and for
the distant universe.
That's actually a picture of
the James Webb Space Telescope.
It was put together at Goddard
in a clean room and that was one
of the days that it
was facing the window.
So it really is huge.
It really is ready to roll.
They're down testing it in Johnson.
It's actually out of testing
now, they're warming it
up in the big chamber where they
did a lot of the Apollo testing.
Next it'll go off to get the sun
should mated to it and it'll launch
from French Guiana in 2019.
We're so excited about
what it's going to find.
And there's also been a lot
of interesting work done
in our own solar system
studying the earth.
There are a lot of planetary
missions that you can turn around
and have them look at the earth.
The picture on the left
is actually an image
that was taken I believe
from Cassini.
You see that little blue
dot in there is the earth
from the distance of Saturn.
And that's better than we're
going to see exoplanets
around other stars,
but it's still so tiny.
But there were efforts made to
tease out the spectrum of the earth,
both in the light that's coming
right towards you and also
as a transmission spectrum
so that when we're looking
at a lunar eclipse, where the sun is
behind the earth and we're looking
at the moon that's red because
the earth is blocking the light
on the moon, but some of the light
is passing through the atmosphere
and bouncing off the moon so you
can get some spectral signatures
of the earth in these ways that are
not directly looking at the earth.
And we know that we can see some
signs in those earth spectra
that tell us that biosignatures
are on the earth.
So that's a really exciting
prospect for the future.
If we can do this same kind of thing
with nearby exoplanets can
we see evidence of water,
evidence of clouds, evidence
of tectonic activity.
We also know that it's possible
if you were to say be looking
at the solar system and you
had a really good telescope
in your alien universe or galaxy,
if you could see the earth and mars
and Venus we know that you
could tell those spectra apart.
They're all small planets.
They're all class to
the habitable zone,
but they have specific
features in their atmosphere
that differentiate them
and particularly as you go
out towards the right of that curve
that's a spectrum and it's going
into the infrared, we can see
that the carbon dioxide feature is
so strong in the earth compared
to Mars, other features in Venus,
all that carbon dioxide in the Venus
atmosphere causing those deep lines.
So this is again exciting
evidence that we may be able
to disentangle features of planets
that tell us if they're earth like
or maybe more like Venus.
There's some really
exciting work going on now
as we plan the telescope
that is going
to be the next generation JWST.
So while we're excited about
launching this huge JWST telescope
in two years we're also thinking
about what have we learned
from building JWST that will
let us take the next step?
Let us build an even larger mirror.
Let us take even more
sensitive measurements.
This is a really exciting simulation
that has just come out recently
by a group at Goddard
led by Aki Roberge.
She's a scientist that's working
on a mission concept called LUVOIR,
the Large Ultraviolet
Optical Infrared telescope.
One of the things they need to know
to build LUVOIR correctly is
what could you expect to see
if you were looking at the solar
system from about 12 parsecs away?
Could you even be able
to disentangle all
that stuff around the sun?
We know there's a lot of
dust in the solar system,
we know that when you're looking
at a star there's all kinds
of stuff in the background.
Background stars, even
background galaxies.
This group has put together an
extremely sophisticated simulation
to help us understand what we would
see if we could look at the earth
from a distance with
something called a coronagraph.
And the coronagraph is
being designed again
to be optimized for LUVOIR.
There's the Hubble mirror, there's
the JWST mirror, look at LUVOIR,
it's going to get yet again
huge but achievable now.
We know we can do something
like this.
Let me show you a little movie
of what a coronagraph does.
[ Music ]
>> A distant star is
orbited by two planets.
One looks similar to the earth,
the other is a gas giant.
When viewed from a distance
the two planets disappear
into the glare of their sun.
How could we ever find these
planets all the way from the earth?
By using a space telescope
with the coronagraph
to separate star light
from planet light.
As the stars light passes through
the telescopes large mirrors,
it picks up small distortions.
Diffraction adds concentric
rings to the image we see.
To reveal the planets, first
a coronagraph uses a mask
to block much of the stars light
and redirect the remaining
light to the outer edges.
A washer shaped device can now block
most of the rest of the stars light.
Because the planets light comes
in at an angle, it misses the mask
and passes through the
center of the washer.
But when we turn up the image
signal by collecting more light,
we can see that the
planets are still hidden
under blobs of leftover star light.
To remove these blobs the
coronagraph has a special deformable
mirror that can change shape by
using hundreds of tiny pistons.
This can correct distortions
in the light beam.
As the mirror deforms,
the blobs of light as seen
in the monitor slowly
begin disappearing,
finally revealing the
brighter of the two planets.
Afterwards, the fainter
planet also comes into view.
We can now see objects more than a
billion times fainter than the star.
And if the light from
these planets is passed
through a prism we can spread
it out into rainbows of color.
But some colors are missing.
They were absorbed by gases
in each planet's atmosphere,
giving us important clues
about their composition.
The search for life in the universe
has taken a new step forward.
[ Music ]
>> Padi Boyd: So that's hopefully
a pretty good explanation
of what a coronagraph does, it's
really exciting engineering and math
and science and software and we
believe is going to be able to cut
down so much of the stars
light that we would be able
to differentiate earth,
Venus and certainly Jupiter
if we had a telescope like
LUVOIR at the right distance.
So this is extremely exciting,
it's definitely our next steps
that we would like to take.
LUVOIR is just one of many large
missions that NASA is studying.
There's four large mission
studies happening right now.
There are two that are
focused on exoplanets.
LUVOIR is one and another
one that is called HAB-X
for Habitable Exoplanets.
They share a lot of
similar characteristics.
They want to have a big mirror, they
want to have a coronagraph on board
so that you can block out
that star light and start
to see the planets light and
take spectra of it and find
out what's in the atmosphere.
But they just have slightly
different mission characteristics.
LUVOIR is meant to do as much in
the distant universe as it is to do
in exoplanets whereas HAB-X is a bit
more focused in it's science case.
But it can also of course do
lots of astrophysics as well.
And we're waiting to see what
the community directs NASA to do.
Every 10 years the country
takes part in a decadal survey
of astrophysics and this directs
the government science centers
about what they should focus
on in the next 10 years.
So we're gearing up for
the next decadal survey,
it'll be happening in 2019 and 2020.
Those four mission studies
I was talking about,
they will be going into
the decadal survey.
We're waiting to hear what
the community of scientists
that are involved in that recommend.
We're certainly hoping LUVOIR
and HAB-X are very highly ranked
so that we can start to really tease
out these exoplanet
atmospheric signatures.
This sort of just does
the sweep of NASA
and ground based astrophysics
missions
that are focused on
exoplanets right now.
I showed you some Hubble
results, some Spitzer results,
we talked about some
ground based results.
We looked at a lot
of Kepler data here.
I told you how excited
we are for TESS
to find those nearby transiting
exoplanets we know we're going
to find and be able to
follow up with Hubble
and the James Webb Space Telescope.
I didn't even get a chance to talk
about the wide field infrared
survey telescope and I can't
because I don't have time, but
it's going to launch as well.
And then that last mission
around the bottom there
is this future mission
that the decadal survey will
tell us what it will be like.
So I hope I have convinced you
that we really are standing
on the edge here of our knowledge of
what we know about our solar system
and extra solar systems and that
we've started to peer back that vail
and put together a much bigger
picture of how planets exist
around stars and we'll take the next
step to determine how they formed
around stars and around our sun and
we are soon to take the next steps
in determining what
those atmospheres
around those planets look like.
And whether or not they have
elements in them that we can tie
to biospheres life or
compatible with life.
So I hope that the next time you
look up in the sky at the milky way,
instead of seeing something that
shows you that there are billions
of stars in just our galaxy
and so any galaxies out there,
that you'll also think
about the planets
that are there that you can't see.
The ones that we didn't
know about when I was a kid
and that we know now are everywhere
and think about what we're going
to find out when your
kids are my age.
It's a great explosive time.
So this is a picture
of Galileo's telescope.
It's a scale model.
And it was brought up on the Hubble
Space Telescope servicing mission,
the last one, by astronaut
John Grunsfeld,
who's also an astrophysicist.
He is known as the Hubble repairman.
He is the last person to teach the
Hubble Space Telescope in orbit.
If you can squint your eyes you
can see both telescopes there.
Galileo's telescope and
the Hubble Space Telescope,
408 years between the two.
And I think we're just
at a very exciting time
where knowledge is
explosive in this area.
So, buckle up and please
keep reading about it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Thank you so much.
And if anyone has questions we'll
take them now and repeat them.
>> Padi Boyd: Okay.
Let's start in the
front and go around.
>> So, just maybe two
questions if I can cheat.
Can we not get a pretty good
idea of the composition of --
particularly the smaller planets?
Or is that what we're most
interested in perhaps.
If we know their density and we
know the mass, we know the size,
can't we tell if there's
perhaps water there
from the density of the planet?
And are we at a point
sometime in the near future
where we might be able
to in fact move
around these larger gas
planets that we've been finding?
So those are great questions.
The first question is about whether
the density gives you everything
that you would need to
know about the planet
and the second question is
whether we can see exomoons,
moons around exoplanets.
So the first one you're
exactly right,
you've hit the nail on the head.
And that's why when I was talking
about TESS I focused on the fact
that we are going to detect a lot of
exoplanets but that we're expecting
that 50 of those we'll
be able to follow
up with ground based
measurements to measure the masses.
So they Kepler and the
transit method in general do,
just gives you the size
of the planet, the radius.
We don't know the mass
until we've measured it
through a different method
usually radial velocity.
And the test targets are going
to be so close and so bright
that we're expecting several
dozen will be amenable
to really accurately
measuring the mass.
And so that if you know the star
very well, the size of the star,
then you know the size of
the planet from the transit.
And once you've got its
mass, you've got its density.
And that gives you a huge amount of
information about the composition
of the planet, it's
bulk composition.
But there's a whole bunch of ways
that you can make an average density
out of, you know, either a
differentiated planet like the earth
where we've got a lot
of iron in the center
and then the crust is a different
density and a slight atmosphere.
You can imagine putting that
together in a slightly different way
where you would still have
the same common density.
So it's a really important step
but it's not enough to
tell you everything.
Yes. Oh, there's a second question.
Exomoons, sorry.
And yes, we do think that the
Kepler telescope was precise enough
that it could have
measured exomoons.
It's a little bit trickier to
do that because it's not --
so the pipeline for Kepler is just
meant to find transiting planets.
Finding transiting exomoons around
a planet requires another level
of effort in the pipeline.
There's a huge amount
of data in the archive.
I wouldn't be surprised if someone
were to try to attack that problem
in the next few years
but to the best
of my knowledge they have not
announced any exomoons yet.
They have announced some
exotrojan asteroids.
So we have the trojan asteroids
in our solar system that are
in very special orbits
compared to the planets.
So they make a triangle, for
example, with the sun, Jupiter
and an equilateral triangle.
There's two areas where
asteroids can be stable
and collect and coagulate.
So if you scale a lot of
the Kepler planetary systems
onto the same scale you can start to
see signs that look very consistent
with trojan asteroids, which
is exactly what you'd expect
because gravity is
the same everywhere.
Yes.
>> You talk a little bit
about the time factor,
Kepler looked at one point and
stays there for a long time
and collects data, but doesn't
make a decision on its own.
The data comes back and decisions
are made once the data is collected.
Is there something that's
coming in like a hound dog idea?
Where you talked about you're
pointing back at the earth
and collecting data [inaudible] that
Goldilocks type of scenario would be
for the earth and then speeding
up the process of changing sectors
and saying, alright,
we were in this area,
we decided this was long enough
to determine the transits,
move to the next area and look for
that type of Goldilocks prospective
of an earth, of whatever that is
from perspective of oxygen or water
or whatever consideration
we're looking
for that we would consider for life.
Is there something like that?
Versus, you don't want
to miss anything
but so much time is
spending on the majority
of things not being the right thing.
>> Padi Boyd: Right.
So the question is
to talk a little bit
about how the time axis impacts
your ability to detect planets
and Kepler pointing
in one direction meant
that while we were really
interrogating one patch
of the sky very intensely,
we were missing almost all
of the sky during that time.
I think that was the point, right?
And so for TESS, so no,
nothing so sophisticated is
in the near term plans like that.
But you can imagine putting
together two simpler missions
to get where you're going.
So, TESS's main difference
from Kepler is that it stares
in one region of the sky with those
four cameras for 27 days only.
And then it's going to rotate
to like a next slice of the sky.
The camera that's at the bottom
or top is basically just rotating
but looking at the same stars.
So those stars would be monitored
continuously for about a year,
whereas the other parts of
the sky we're only going
to have 27 days worth
of data on those stars.
So we're going to be -- it's
a preferentially red filter
so we're going to be preferentially
finding transits around those dim,
low mass stars where you can
see habitable zone planets
in a short amount of time.
But, currently there's no effort
to dynamically change
your time length based
on what you've found so far.
You can use the TESS results
to then go to telescopes
and do the more sophisticated stuff.
Yes.
>> When you [inaudible]
biosignatures
of the [inaudible] that you will.
What's the degree of
certainty will you have
that you've found something
that might signify life?
>> Padi Boyd: Oh that's
a really great question.
And there's actually a lot
of people that are working
on that particular question.
As I was talking about earlier,
exoplanets has become
extremely multidisciplinary.
So you know the astrophysicists
are capable
of developing these amazing
telescopes with the ability,
you know, to really detect
signatures in a spectra.
But we also need atmospheric
scientists to do modeling
that tells us what are
the possible sources
of that feature in an atmosphere.
What could be tricking us?
You know, what could look like
a biosignature that isn't?
And so we're using all kinds
of information that we have
from earth science and from
planetary science and just
from modeling to start to
answer those questions.
So I think it's going to be very
similar to the answer about like,
once you've got the mass does
that nail down everything
that the planet is made of?
If we're going to have a
similar answer for spectral lines
and potential biosignatures.
I think when we find something we'll
know it as a potential biosignature,
they we're going to have to do an
awful lot of work modeling theory
and just measuring many other
systems before we have a sense
of how secure we are in that.
>> Just a follow up, and then
what would be the next step
in what's [inaudible]
on that modeling.
What would be the hope like you
said when our kids at your age?
Or each generations.
>> Padi Boyd: So I actually
-- so I have a seven year old
and I am fairly confident that when
he's my age he's going to be able
to go outside with his kids and
point to a couple stars in the sky
and say, that one right over there
has a planet a lot like earth.
We know it's about the right size,
we know that liquid water
does exist there and we think
that there could be life
because we know of these things.
The next step is not
up to my generation.
Keep going this way
and then come back.
Yes.
>> I know there was an
earlier mission proposed
that hasn't been launched
yet or planned
to track terrestrial planet finder.
Is there an upcoming mission
that's analogous to that
or how far off will the terrestrial
planet finder type mission be
in the [inaudible]?
>> Padi Boyd: So, some elements
of the terrestrial planet
finder the LUVOIR concept.
But you can think of LUVOIR
as a reengineered version
of the terrestrial planet finder.
So the question was,
how soon will something
like the terrestrial
planet finder be realized?
So, LUVOIR takes some
of the best ideas
of the terrestrial planet finder
and it takes all the information
that we have right now about the
exoplanet populations we know
of to design a mission that
can really tell us something
about what we know
we're going to see.
When the terrestrial planet finder
was first being designed we didn't
really know that much about the
exoplanet population out there
and then some of the other things
that might have made it very
challenging to visually see planets
like how much dust
was in the system.
But we're taking what we're
learning now about systems
to make LUVOIR even
stronger and better.
There's always a next step though
and there's people that are thinking
about what do we do
even beyond the LUVOIR?
And so there are some ideas about
building super large mirrors
in space using astronauts or
robots near the space station,
where you could launch pieces of
it and put it together like a Lego.
And then of course, very
much more sophisticated
coronagraph technology.
The movie that I showed
you about where we're going
in coronagraphs now, we've made huge
strides there in the past decade
but we've got a long way to go
there too and you can see some kind
of transformative technology there
for direct imaging that you'd want
to fold into the next
mission as well.
Yes.
>> Ages ago I remember reading
that we shouldn't get too excited
about exoplanets because there's
so many double stars out there
and double stars were less
likely to have planets.
I didn't hear you mention
double stars at all.
>> Padi Boyd: You are right,
I didn't have time to
mention them at all.
So you may remember
that scene in Star Wars
where Luke Skywalker goes
back to his childhood home
and he sees something terrible
and he goes out on a hill
and he watches the sunset and it's
two stars that are setting, not one.
And people said at the time George
Lucas, that was fantastical.
You're not going to have any stable
planets around binary star systems.
There are actually planets
around binary star systems
when we found them with Kepler.
The first concubinary planets
were found just a few years
after the mission launched and
there's quite a collection of them.
So that opens up a whole
new set of questions
about the stability
of planetary systems.
Where did they form?
Do they form somewhere
else and migrate in?
Do they form around one star
or did the whole system
form, you know, as one?
And have they interacted,
have then been around one star
for a while and the other?
It's fun, it's a lot of
fun dynamics in that one.
Yes?
>> Actually yeah, my question
was sort of based on that.
How does binary or even tertiary
that has ever been in the situation,
how does it affect the means for
Kepler and maybe future tests
to elaborate on these
exoplanet findings?
Have they impeded or
have they, I guess,
lead to more fascinating
[inaudible].
>> Padi Boyd: So the question
is, how does the binarity
of many stars impact the
results that we're talking
about with Kepler and TESS?
So we know that about half the
stars in our galaxy are found
in binaries and half are single.
And lots of what I talked about
was sort of implicitly suggesting
that they are single stars.
And in fact we know that
about half of them aren't.
So there's a great effort that goes
into taking a Kepler planet
candidate and turning it
into a Kepler confirmed planet.
And one of the things
we have to watch
out for the most is whether
a binary star is tricking us.
Because if you see a planet that's
going around one star you're going
to get a certain size estimate.
But if it's actually two stars
that are giving you the flux
from the star, then the transits
going to look much smaller
and you're going to make the mistake
that the planet is
smaller than it really is.
So there are efforts that go into
like direct imaging of these systems
to see if we can get very
high resolution imaging
and look for binary pairs.
If they're very far away
that's also very challenging.
So there's also some
statistical arguments
about whether this is a
single star or a binary
and then also we can
look at the data itself
and see how the light moves
on the detector to determine
if there's something fooling us.
Yes? Should I take
one more question?
It's 12:31.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Yeah.
>> Padi Boyd: Okay.
>> Can you speak at all --
you didn't mention if there was
any significance to the location
of where these missions
were looking.
Like Kepler seemed like it was
kind of a somewhat arbitrary area.
This spot and this distance away.
And then the next mission is
looking 200 light years away.
>> Padi Boyd: Mmm-hmm.
>> They're both, with
Kepler the location
but also the distance
of the two of those.
Is there a reason why they matter?
>> Padi Boyd: Sure.
So the question is say
something a little bit about,
basically the mission design.
Why was Kepler chosen
to look where it looked?
And why is TESS looking at the 200
light year sphere around the earth?
So, yes, there are good reasons.
And there was a lot of debate
and discussion and collaboration
that went into deciding what
the final Kepler field would be.
We knew in order to do the
mission it has to be staring,
so it had to be somewhere where it
could look for four years straight.
We wanted to have lots and
lots of stars like the sun,
so you needed a relatively
dense patch of the sky.
But you didn't want to be
so close to the milky way
that you had a lot of crowding.
That your typical star would
have other stars nearby
that would dilute the signal.
So you wanted to get far
enough off the milky way plane
that you would have about
150,000 sun like stars
that you could put little
postage stamp patches
to get the light curves.
And another reason that
that position was chosen was
because there were a lot of ground
based telescopes that could get
on the part of the sky pretty
quickly to confirm the planets.
For TESS, once TESS was being
finalized we of course knew
from Kepler that planets
were everywhere and so
that made the choice
of looking close,
looking nearby, much, much better.
You know, we know they're
going to be there.
So now you can design TESS in
a way that's a lot different
than we designed most astrophysics
missions where we're trying
to look at really dim things.
TESS is really meant to
look at bright stars.
Most telescopes saturate when
you look at bright stars.
But TESS won't.
So, it was intentionally designed to
be shallow so that it's only going
out to 200 light years
because we know there are more
than enough stars in that
area that it is sensitive
to that we expect thousands
of planets and hundreds
to be with measured masses.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Well, thank you very much.
>> Padi Boyd: Thank you.
Thanks for all your good questions.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.